[موسيقى]
يقول الفيلسوف البريطاني بارتراند راسل في
يوم من الايام شاهدت فتى متوسطه البنيه
يضرب فتى اصغر منه جادلته لم تعتدي عليه
وهو لا يقدر عليك فاجاب الاولاد الكبار
ايضا يضربونني فانا اضرب من هم اصغر مني
بهذه الكلمات يختم بير تراند لخص الطفل كل
تاريخ الانسانيه الى العناوين
روسيا لن تهزم وبيض ينعش كياف
موسكو تذكر ماكرون بنهايه نابليون
وزيلينسكي بمصير هتلر
ابو غزاله من جديد حرب عالميه قبل نهايه
العام
الازهر والفاتيكان يغيبان عن افتتاح بيت
العائله الابراهيميه
اسرائيل تحمل الجزائر مسؤوليه طردها من
القمه الافريقيه
محاكمه محمد مرسي في القاهره لم تنتهي رغم
وفاته
في ذكرى رفيق الحريري سعد يقرا الفاتحه
وبهاء يضيف الخمور
مرحبا فيما زلزله الارض واهتزت ولم تستكن
بعد في تركيا وبعض نواحي الشام يرتفع صخب
المسرح الدولي على وقع خطاب فلاديمير
بوتين بالذكرى الاولى لحربه على اوكرانيا
يؤكد فيه استحاله هزيمه روسيا في الميدان
مع انه هو من صنع الميدان وجاء الى
اوكرانيا
في عاصمتها بعلم بوتين جو بايدن فجاه وعلى
عجل وكانه يقول ليفلودي ميرزيلنسكي امضي
ونحن معك سنمدكم بالسلاح تقتلون به
وتقتلون دفاعا عن الحريه التي نحرم منها
الفلسطينيين وسنرد بشكل مناسب لانه في هذه
الحاله الحديث يدور عن وجود دولتنا لكنهم
ايضا لا يسعهم الا ان يدركوا انهم
المستحيل هزيمه روسيا بصحه المعركه عذرا
جنرال بوتين لكن قرار هزيمه روسيا صدر عن
عندليب الاليزيه كما يوصف ايمانيول ماكرون
لكن ماكرون يطمئنك سيد بوتين بانه لا يرغب
في سحق روسيا الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل اكد
استعداد بلاده لخوض نزاع طويل الامد مشددا
على رغبته في هزيمه روسيا ولكن من دون سحق
على حد وصفه وعلى لسان ماريا زخروف
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه ذكرت ماكرون بمصير
نابليون ورفاته الموقره الراقده في قلب
باريس وفق تعبير زخرف التي اضافت بشكل عام
مكروم بلا قيمه
فقد ذكرته روسيا به هتلر وذلك على لسان
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قاديروف الذي كشف
عن احتفاضه ليزيلنسكي بنفس المسدس الذي
تقول بعض الروايات ان هتلر انتحر به
انا احتفظ بمسدس من نفس نوع المسدس الذي
اطلق منه هتلر النار على نفسه
سارسله لك هل يستطيع بنيامين نتنياهو ان
يقنع صديقه فلاديمير بوتين بالانسحاب من
اوكرانيا لانه ان استطاع فان مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون السياسيه
فيكتوريا نولاند اعلنت انها ستمنح عندئذ
نتنياهو جائزه نوبل للسلام زخاه زخاروفا
جاهزه دائما للاطلاق فهي لم تكن تعلم ان
نولاند هي من يقرر عن لجنه نوبل
الجوائز ونصحتها بتكريم نتنياهو بعد تسويه
الصراع في الشرق الاوسط واقامه دوله
فلسطين
بكامل الحقوق بكل الاحوال كيف ستستطيع
اسرائيل ان تلعب دور الوسيط المحايد
معنيتها تقديم الدعم العسكري والمالي
اوكرانيا اعلنغوه
دفاع جوي وتقديم قرض مالي بقيمه 200 مليون
دولار وسط كل هذا الضجيج مع روسيا يحاول
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بعث نصف رساله
تهدئه الى الصين فهو يرغب بالتحدث الى
رئيسها لكنه لا يعتذر عن فقر قواته من طاب
التجسس التي تنفي الصين انه كان للتجسس
اعرب رئيس الامريكي جاب بايدن تعليقا على
اختراق الاجسام المجهوله للاجواء
الامريكيه عرض عن رغبته في التحدث مع رئيس
الصيني بشان المنطاد الذي اسقطه الجيش
الامريكي مؤكدا انه لا يرغب في حرب بارده
مع
حتى لو رضي الرئيس الصين والرئيس امريكا
بطي صفحه بالبارده او الساخنه هل يقبل
طلال ابو غزاله من جديد يبشركم ابو غزاله
لا تنتهي هذه السنه قبل اندلاع الحرب
العالميه هل تعتقد انه الحرب العالميه
الثالثه قادمه مئه بالمئه وتنتظر شراره
انا توقعي
بنهايه هذا العام بنكون شاهدنا الحرب
العالميه انا قلت من اول باب اطلق بدات
الحرب هاي ليست حرب على اوكرانيا ولا على
اوروبا
ولا حرب محليه ولا اقليميه هي بدايه الحرب
العالميه كلام ابو غزاله لا يعاكسه الرجل
الاعمال السوري رامي مخلوف الذي باتي
يتقمص شخصيتي المنجم والمتصوف في ان واحد
فينظر السوريين من حروب قادمه وزلازل
وبراكين وفيضانات وكل هذا لانه شلحوه
مصرياته بدمشق
فيبشر ببدء عصر الظهور ظهور الامام المهدي
عليه السلام ويعتبر ان الزلزال الاخير هو
اشاره البدء والقاضب اعنف طيب شو بنعمل يا
رامي بهالوقت يجيب لا ينفع الان الا
الدعاء والعمل الصالح للنجاه كيف وشو
الاسلوب وكيف الامور هذا بيحتفظ فيه لحالي
مقياس ومخلوه كان اقصى من مقياس رختر الذي
سجل زلزلين جديدين في تركيا بلغ هما سته
فاصل اربع درجات
وهزات ارتداديه ضربت لبنان وسوريا وفلسطين
في لبنان تحديدا الرعب كبير من وقوع اي
كارثه مع شبه انعدام قدرات الدوله لمال
ولا امكانيات ولا رئيس ولا حكومه ولا سمير
فرج اللواء المصري الذي صار مشهورا بهز
كتفه يهز الكتف يفتح الدرج ليعالج اسوا
الكوارث كل شيء مدروس النهارده لو حصل اي
ازمه في مصر هقعد لسه ادور وافكر لا
الكلام ده موجود في الدرج سيناريوهات لكل
ازمات موجوده في مصر اي حاجه كله من فوق
لو ازمه رغيف عيش في منطقه
[موسيقى]
افتتح في ابوظبي ما اطلق عليه بيت العائله
الابراهيميه الذي يضم مسجدا وكنيسه وكنيسا
في مربع واحد يقول مطلقوه انه يهدف الى
تعزيز حوار الاديان ويضم البيت ثلاثه دور
عباده مسجدا وكنيسه وكنيسه ويوفر بيت
العائله الابراهيميه ملتقا ومعرضا وحديقه
كما يدعو المعرض العام الى التامل في
عباداته ومعتقدات الديانات الابراهيميه
طيب خلال التامل في معتقدات ما اسموه
الديانات الابراهيميه الى اي نتيجه يمكن
ان يتوصلوا مثلا في تحديد شخصيه السيد
المسيح عليه السلام هو في الديانه
اليهوديه ما تعلمون وفي الديانه المسيحيه
هو ابن الله ويسوع الرب وفي الاسلام هو
عبد الله ورسوله عليه السلام بالتاكيد
يتوصلوا الى اي نتيجه فلو شاء ربك لجعل
الناس امه واحده
سيقولون دعونا من الخلافات العقائديه وهذا
هو الاصل لا تفتش في عقيدتي ولا افتش في
عقيدتك بل دعونا نفتش عن الفقراء
والموجوعين في هذا العالم المضطرب عن سبل
التعاون الانساني لما فيه مصلحه مشتركه
لكل البشر قلنا في بدايه الكلام ما اسموها
الديانات الابراهيميه ليس لملاحظه فلسفيه
او لغويه منا بل نقلا للامانه العلميه
الموثقه بتصريحات شيوخ الازهر وعلماء
اخرين يذكرون بان الله تعالى يخبرنا في
الايه السابعه والستين من سوره ال عمران
في القران الكريم الذي يؤمن بكله كل
المسلمين بان لنبي الله ابراهيم عليه
السلام
ديانه واحده ولم ينسب القران اليه عده
ديانات لينسبها المسلمون اليه ما كان
ابراهيم
يهوديا ولا نصرانيا ولكن
حنيفا
حنيفا مسلما وما كان من المشركين مفتي
سلطنه عمان الشيخ احمد بن حمد الخليلي
اطلق تحذيرا علميا قاسيا جدا من فكره دمج
الاديان اما شيخ الازهر الامام الاكبر
احمد الطيب الذي هاجم قبل عده شهور ما
اعتبره ترويجا لما يسمى بالديانه
الابراهيميه الجديده فقط قاطع افتتاح ما
سمي ببيت العائله الابراهيميه رغم ان
المسجد المقام فيه يحمل اسمه مسجد الامام
احمد الطيب الى جانب كنيس موسى بن ميمون
وكنيسه البابا فرنسيس الذي لم يذكر الخبر
الرسمي للافتتاح وجود او مشاركه اي ممثل
عنه في ظل التوجهات التي تنادي
بالابراهيميه
او الدين الابراهيمي وما تطمح اليه هذه
التوجهات فيما يبدو
من مسجد اليهوديه والمسيحيه والاسلام في
رساله واحده او دين واحد هذه الدعاوى وان
كانت تبدو في ظاهرها او في ظاهره امرها
وكانها دعوه الى الاجتماع الانساني
وتوحيده والقضاء على اسباب نزاعاته
وصراعاته الا انها هي نفسها وفي حقيقه
الامر
دعوه الى مصادره اغلى ما يمتلكه بنو
الانسان وهو حريه الاعتقاد وحريه الايمان
وحريه الاختيار الفكره ليست جديده على
المنطقه الشيخ محمد بن صالح العثيمين حذر
منها قبل عشرات السنين ويجب ان نحذر من
بادره بدات تفوح رائحتها الكريهه الا وهي
ما يسمى بتوحيد الاديان فان هذا المبدا
منكر عظيم قال الله تبارك وتعالى اليوم
اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت عليكم نعمتي ورضيت
لكم الاسلام دينا وقال عز وجل ومن يبتغي
غير الاسلام دينا فليقبل منه فكيف يليق
بنا ان نحاول ما يسمى بتوحيد الاديان
يبدو ان الجزائر قد سنت سنه في افريقيا
وهي اطردوا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حيث
ثقفتموه فللعام الثاني على التوالي يمنع
الوفد الاسرائيلي المتطفل بدون اي دعوه من
حضور قمه الاتحاد الافريقي التي انعقدت
هذه المره في اديس ابابا واتهام اسرائيل
للجزائر بالوقوف وراء الطرد كان حاضرا في
تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين قام امنوا
قمه الاتحاد الافريقي بطرد وفد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من القاعه التي احتضنت الجلسه
الافتتاحيه لقمه الاتحاد الافريقي بعدما
تسلل اليها خلسه مستعملا بطاقات دخول
لاشخاص اخرين ودعا الوفد الصهيوني ان لديه
دعوه لحضور جلسه افتتاح القمه لكنه لم
يتمكن من اثبات ذلك نفذ الفلسطينيون عصيا
بدعوه مشتركه من مختلف الحركات عم بلدات
القدس المحتله ومخيم رفضا لاجراءات
الاحتلال واعتداءاته التي تصاعدت مع احياء
ذكرى الاسراء والمعراج التي حاول
الفلسطينيون في القدس والضفه الحفاظ قدر
المستطاع امنيا واقتصاديا على احتفالاتهم
التقليديه بها
سيدنا محمد الى السماء
العربي قدروا هذه الارض وهذا القدس الشريف
هذا واحنا بنتامل ان شاء الله ربنا السنه
الجايه تبقى محررين يا رب العالمين يا
الله سخر مستوطنون متدينون حريدين من
العرب برقصه تمثيليه بشعه تشوه اللباس
العربي اقيمت في احد الاعراس غرب القدس
المحتله علما انهم لطالما رقصوا مسرورين
ضاحكين خلال اعيادهم الدينيه مع بحرينيين
في المنام يرتدون الزي العربي
وفيما يلي رقصه اخرى لهم غير تمثيليه من
الاحتفال السنوي بعيد خلاص الحمار
[موسيقى]
نائب بحريني كان يتحدث خلال جلسه برلمانيه
عن انه سمع بان الاسرائيليين سوف يستثمرون
في جزر البحرين فطلب منه الرئيس البرلمان
التوقف فورا عن الكلام وقال له استريح مع
انه كان مرتاحا جدا
راح يستثمر في جزر هذه مشكله
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه دفعت الاف
التونسيين للخروج في شوارع صفاقس ومحافظات
تونسيه اخرى بناء على دعوه من الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل المطالب المعيشيه
رافقتها مطالب تتعلق بحمايه الحقوق
والحريات
السيد الرئيس هذا
جميع الاطراف الاطراف السياسيه والاطراف
الاجتماعيه ومغيب الاتحاد وفي عام القطيع
مع الناس الكل ويحكم وحده ما هو اسهل جواب
للرد على كل هذه الاتهامات للرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد بمصادره الحياه السياسيه
والاقتصاديه وربما الاجتماعيه قريبا في
البلاد
ارهابيون الشعب ارهابي يحتاج الى تربيه
يعلقون الذين تم اعتقالهم ارهابيين
ولابد ايضا ان يحاسبوا بالقانون ولكن لم
نترك تونس لقمه
لهؤلاء المجرمين
الارهابيين الذين يريدون التنكير بالشعب
التونسي وضربت دوله التونسيه مش واحد
ارهابيين محمد مرسي ايضا الرئيس المصري
الراحل تدرجه النيابه العامه المصريه على
قوائم الارهاب بعد ثلاث سنوات على وفاته
فهل يوضع القرار عند قبره مع توزع اسرته
بين شهيد وشهيد يقول انصار مرسي من جانبها
استنكرت مؤسسه مرسي للديمقراطيه ادراج
الرئيس محمد مرسي على قوائم الارهاب بعد
ثلاث سنوات على ارتقائه شهيدا النائب
العراقي السابق صالح المطلق يعيب على رئيس
الحكومه العراقيه محمد شياع السوداني انه
تربى خارج العراق ثم جاء مع الاحتلال
ويريد ان يكون قائدا لشعبه على حد تعبيره
تربى خارج العراق وجاء مع الاحتلال
الاحتلال بلده اي مجتمع حر يفترض انه ما
يتقبل شخص يضع ايده بايد محتلو ويجيبه
يقول له احتل بلدي حتى انا ولماذا رجمه
محمد شياع السوداني دون غيره في بغداد هل
يوجد رئيس حكومه عراقي بعد الاحتلال
الامريكي لم يتعامل مع الاحتلال يسال سائل
ويتذكر هذا المقطع لعادل امام
كل واحد عزل عشان تحت واحده رقاصه البلد
كلها حداد في الشارع
ذكرى اغتيال الرئيس الوزراء لبنان الاسبق
رفيق الحريري احياها الاسبوع الماضي نجله
الرئيس السابق سعد الحريري الذي علق عمله
السياسي بقراءه الفاتحه المباركه على روح
ابيه مع حشد من انصاره انتوا الناس الطيبه
اللي بكيت على الحريري
وهذا البيت حيضل له مكمل هالمشوار باذن
الله الله يخليكم
والله يجزيكم خير والله يرحم الشهيد رفيق
الحريري وخلينا نقرا الفاتحه على روحه وعن
روح الرئيس رفيق الحريري وزعت الخمور بحسب
تعليق بيروتيين اما الموزع فهو نزله الاخر
رجل الاعمال بهاء الحريري الذي احيا ذكرى
رحيل والده بحفل في امريكا وزعت خلاله
الخمور على الحضور في لبنان وامريكا تدخل
الخمور ضمن كرم الضيافه عند كثيرين لكن
ليس خلال احياء ذكرى الشهداء والموتى لا
يحدث ذلك لا عند المسلمين ولا عند
المسيحيين لا يوزعون الخمور ولا الجلاب
قهوه فقط قهوه
اما خارج احياء ذكرى الموتى فلشان لاحد
بمشاريب الضيافه طيب شو ما بدك بقول لك
بهيج واعزمه كمان الذكرى 18 الاغتيال
الرئيس رفيق الحريري لم تمر مرور الكرام
في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن بل ارادها
ابنه البكر بهاء الحريري مناسبه لتكريم
استمراريه نهج ومشروع رفيق الحريري وكذلك
لاحياء الذكرى العاشره لتاسيس مركز رفيق
الحريري سؤال يطرحه مراقب محايد على زعماء
سنه لبنان هل يعتقدون ان التعايش والتكامل
مع الشريك المسيحي في الوطن يتوطد من خلال
الابتعاد عن عادات المسلمين وعباداتهم
ابرز زعيم مسيحي في لبنان الرئيس السابق
الجنرال ميشال عون تحالف للعظم مع السيد
حسن نصر الله الذي لا يضيف الخمور ولا
يشربها وحتى لا يصافح النساء بل ويع
بولايه الولي الفقيه ويلتزم فتاويه في
الدين والدنيا وكذلك يقيم الزعيم المسيحي
البارز سليمان فرنجيه وحزب التصنيق
الارمني وكثيرون اخرون حلفا لم يتزعزع مع
السيد نصر الله وحزب الله في المقابل الف
الجنرال ميشال عون وكتلته النيابيه كتابا
اسموه الابراء المستحيل يتهمون فيه
السياسات الاقتصاديه للرئيس الراحل رفيق
الحريري وتياره بالفساد هيكليه الدوله في
السلطات في سلطه تنفيذيه هي المسؤوله بدها
تتحاسب
فنان تونسي اسمه حموده كوكا اسمه محمد
لكنه يصرح عن كرهه الشديد للحجاب الاسلامي
وتحدثه نفسه دائما بالاعتداء على المحجبات
بتمزيق حجابهم بل ويعتبر المحجبه ادنى
قيمه من الانسان
هذا لا رد عليه لان مصطلحاته توصف
بالبلطجيه والسوقيه وطريقه الوحيده
للتعامل معه هي رفع دعاوى قضائيه عليه من
محجبات متضررات من كلامه في كل دول العالم
بتهمه القطع والذم واهانه نساء المسلمين
ليكون عبره لكل معتوه يتطاول على المراه
يعلق معلق معناها هي ادنى اقل قيمه وهذا
خلاني انا دائما عندي
الكره للحاجه اسمها حجاب معناها بصوره
مذبيه امراه عن اللاعب
الانسانيه امراه تنكر الانسانيه متاعها
كوكا هذا يعترف على الهواء بان لديه ابن
زنا نعم ابن زنا وفق المفهوم الشرعي
الاسلامي واللاهوتي المسيحي وحتى اليهودي
يقولوا انه انجب طفلا من علاقه غير شرعيه
ثم حضر الولد ثمره العلاقه غير الشرعيه
عرسه ابويه البيولوجيين فهما وان تزوجا
لاحقا ليس ابويه الشرعيين بالمفاهيم
الدينيه للمسلمين ولاهل الكتاب انا في
فرنسا
في الفيل ولدي واحنا في البلديه بتاع
[موسيقى]
هو هو حاضر واحنا
ختاما اشار فتى صغير يقف على قارعه طريق
ريفي مستغيثا برجل يعبر الطريق بسيارته
الجديده ولما لم يتوقف رماه بحجر كسر
النافذه الخلفيه توقف الرجل ونزل غاضبا
معلفا الفتى الذي لم يهرب لما فعلت هذا
اليس لك اهل يربوك اجابه الطفل بخوف شديد
وهو يبكي عذرا سيدي لي فقط اخ كبير هناك
اشار اليه انه مقعد على كرسي متحرك تعثرت
عجلاته بحفره سقط فيها وهو الان يتالم
وانا لا اقوى على سحبه منها
لم تتوقف اي سياره لمساعده يضيف فكان علي
ان ارمي هذا الحجر تاثر الرجل بالموقف
وبتوسلات الفتى فقدم غيضه وسحب الشاب
المقعد من الحفره والخلاصه لا تمضي في
الحياه مسرعا دون الاهتمام بمحيطك وبدل ان
توقفك الاحجار دع اخلاقك الكريمه تفعل ذلك
الى اللقاء ندخل
نزرع بساتي وزهور ننشر امل والمجتمع فينا
فخر ورحلها شعوب
[موسيقى]